assalam alaykum now you're going to see
two individuals in this next video one
if he keeps on this straight pass he's
headed towards success and the other one
is headed towards destruction anxiety
and a lot a lot of pain let's get into
this clip today is the day of resigned
for being a Muslim I'm a new man I'm a
new man well he officially sold a soul
if this is true this is one of the
biggest sins it's it's too bad you can't
really believe a lot of what he says but
even joking about this is is insane he
was born with Islam so leave his culture
leave his faith behind for clout for
fame for parties to be in a relationship
with an online it's a shame if he
follows down this path he's going to
become extremely depressed and so you
think now that you could leave Islam
because you have temporary Fame a lot of
these people don't like you I saw the
video like you thought the lot of people
that were surrounding your van were your
fans these people were saying neon neon
is a Fame is not something that you
should be chasing it's not real you
should be chasing a positive impact you
should have something that you want to
share with your audience you should be
trying to uplift create Inspire Fame is
garbage Gabriel how you
doing good to have you back on a
program I opened up I said one person's
headed towards success the other
person's headed towards destruction
which one is
itd I must start by saying that I'm
impressed with with
sneo CU I've seen some of his stuff from
few years back the way he was obviously
on fresh and fit podcast at the
beginning with the red pill
community
and he's embraced Islam alhamdulillah
may Allah bless uh she man also for the
work that he's done in investing this
guy you know and this shows how
important it is to have someone behind
you to help you to guide you and such a
big change that we notice in his
behavior in his speech a lot of people
might be like yeah but he's still this
and still that it takes time he's coming
you see he's coming long manah I mean
even some of his latest and okay I'm not
saying that he should be on that podcast
but some of his latest discussions he's
totally changed narrative he's you can
see how Islam is taking over Islam is
taking over you're talking here about a
guy who is a streamer very famous
and he's on this spectrum Fame very well
known makes money and Islam is pulling
him now away from that Fame away you
have to understand the fitna of being so
famous of having money being around all
these girls and Islam is changing him as
the prophet s said when the sahab were
objecting to one man who entered Islam
for whatever reasons okay and the
sahabas thought that it's not good they
were a bit judgmental when it came to it
and the prophet said leave him because
Islam will take over his heart slowly
yeah and that's what's happening with
sneo on the other side of the extreme
you have this neon guy who's neon neon
is another streamer another po whatever
gamer gamer streamer yes so you can say
like sneo neon almost around the same
typee of uh you know neighborhood walk
you know the same thing same background
but neon was born into a Muslim
family and the fame and know he getting
more famous because he's been hanging
around with the wrong people in the
wrong
crowd is pulling him away from Islam so
sneo is being pulled towards Islam by
the dean he's putting in the work and
the action putting in the work you got
to put in work and then you see the
progress 100% and this guy neon is
putting in the work with the withan and
moving away from Islam not putting in
the work like he should be praying Salah
like sneo what you he was talking about
umra he made umra he made umra withman
mallah and he's praying and you can see
he's learning see his talk he the words
he's using this a proof of Islam you get
to the gym you're going to see results
you got the weights the nutrition you do
the right thing for your body you're
going to see the results you do Islam
you get results you get results it was
it was really it was part just him
saying sallallahu alai wasallam you look
how like the f one of the first things
that changes when you change your speech
is when you say mamed you say sallam
peace be upon him yes and and and Allah
says in the
Quran and we raise your remembrance look
at that anyone who becomes Muslim one of
the first adjustments that you say when
you speak about the prophet wasam you're
going to mention peace and blessings be
upon it's just beautiful to see and the
other young young guy Young Brother uh
he's talking about leaving leaving Islam
but really was he even ever in Islam
that's the thing allaham but according
to what he was saying some of the
previous videos he was saying that I'm a
Muslim I'm proud Muslim and now since
he's gotten with this girl only fans
girl it really took a different turn
he's been mixing around with all these
weird stars from the adult industry and
just bad things and it's basically in
this video he said that today I'm in new
man basically he's renouncing Islam even
not a joke there's no joke about this
this is serious if someone says that
what he say he said I'm a new man I'm a
new man you know this is the day that
I'm not whatever Muslim anymore whatever
he said basically clearly he's
renouncing Islam so he's choosing his
God now because it's now he's worshiping
this woman now indeed this is what seems
to be happening if you and I don't look
into these things but people send me a
lot of these videos say what do you
think about this what do you think about
that so I do see some of these reactions
and some of these videos this is
important for other people who are young
young Muslims and others who will see
like the two they'll contrast see okay
sneo was there been there he's getting
out of it slowly and he's going more
towards Islam most of the young guys do
know these guys because they're famous
streamers kids play games they follow
these dudes and they definitely know
them and you have an example here
someone coming from Fame towards Islam
and look what's he's saying he said Fame
is going to lead you to depression
you're chasing validation and fame and
you're going to have this miserable life
as Allah says in the Quran and one guy
is going from Islam running towards
Fame and they're going in opposite
directions I mean if that's if someone's
been down a road and that road now is a
road of Destruction Minefield and the
person comes back and says don't go down
the road no doubt there's minefields the
bridge is out you're you're going to
fall why you it's like people have to
touch the fire they want to go towards
the fire it's very strange uh this
phenomenon that we see where in Muslim
countries Muslims born Muslims are
moving
towards kuur mhm people are leaving
Islam people are saying things doing
things and you have now people are
coming from a non-muslim background
who've experienced
everything and they're saying I'm I I'm
missing there's not something missing
everything is missing I'm done with this
I'm done with this I need Islam is my my
peace my Liberation The Liberation of my
soul you're talking about people have
gone so
far and made the
realization and our own brothers and
sisters who were giving the gift of
Muhammed from birth from their parents
they're saying I don't want it mhm how
many people we've met how many people
what's the Hadith where the Prophet s
said and paraphrasing uh someone will go
to bed a Believer wake up a disbeliever
yeah they imagine that so towards the
end of time that's what's going to
happen someone will wake up has a you
know he's a Believer he's going to go to
sleep as his disbeliever and someone is
going to you know is the other the
opposite so it shows this Hadith shows
how easy is going to be to literally
like exit within a span of like 8 hours
within a span of of a few hours you can
change your life you can go to hell can
lose yourself that's it and then another
Hadith that comes to mind is where the
Prophet Muhammad peace and bl be upon
him last and final mess sent to mankind
he
describes Jenna and all the um obstacles
in front of it and then the Hellfire and
all of the obstacles the pleasures and
everything so we can see which one is
taking that path this nion neo pleasure
desire it's the pleasures but then it's
the poison inside and the worse than the
poison is the Hellfire a Hellfire Subhan
Allah if he doesn't snap out of it I
hope he snaps out of it I hope he's
listening because I know he is close or
they talk him and neon talk I hope sorry
yes I hope sneo becomes an ambassador of
the dean a day and it's important here
why people are saying what's your
obsession with these guys
what's your obsession with Andrew Tate
what's your obsession with sneo what's
your obsession with all these famous
people we don't need these people I
agree with you Islam doesn't need these
people but from a prophetic approach of
the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
you have to understand that the prophet
Sall wasallam did pay attention to the
leaders of the qur Allah subhana
rectified and uh fixed certain things
and and warn them about certain issues
but indeed part of his daah is that he
did focus and give special attention
towards some of these leaders some of
these
influencers and Abu sufyan is one of
them even at fat meca he gave him a
special position and this is the wisdom
and the Strategic dawa that is prophetic
so indeed for us when we talk about
these famous people I'm you know you
bring a lot on the on The Dean show you
talk about a lot you react to the videos
a lot of people I see the comments like
oh why we don't need this it's
because they have
influence and the people who follow them
can easily themselves change their lives
human psychology as such you cannot
disconnect the message from the
messenger you cannot disconnect the
person human beings are linked to
personalities we have con connections so
it's very important to always remember
that alhamdulillah if someone like that
becomes Muslim and he changes himself no
doubt he does the right da many people
can enter Isam and alhamdulillah we we
wish for that you kind of see yourself
you and many of these people and you're
rooting for them because you see
yourself you we've been there done that
and now you see like someone like Andrew
Tate or sneo or whoever else is out
there and you know like okay you there
you kind of had the same experiences you
know what they were chasing chasing the
same thing it was a dead end and you
know now that now if they Implement like
sneako doing Islam they're going to reap
the benefits they're going to end up
being peace in their hearts that void is
going to be filled and now and if they
go above and beyond they start doing
daah at the same time the benefits that
they can they can benefit so many so
many more people like uh it's nice to
see sneo he's also sharing giving the
Quran and sharing with people doing da
doing da amazing I mean I'm very we're
rooting for I'm really yeah I mean look
both you and I were coming from
backgrounds you know really you knowa we
don't want to talk about that right
openly but alhamdulillah we're here and
we hope for those people to be better
than us inshallah even better than us
yes right inshallah yeah absolutely and
especially now this young Neo neon Neo
and then it's sad to see a person like
him he's got a treasure on one end Islam
is a treasure it's more than a treasure
you cannot substitute with any kind of
money you can't buy the the gift of hi
you can't and he's giv it away for a
piece of what uh for a piece of uh these
people don't value him in the in the
first place and this what sne was saying
they don't value they make fun of you
but because you have money and you have
some Fame now people are you think that
girl is with him because of his looks or
his come on and this is so
important you know a woman can make or
break you know you pick the wrong woman
you get influenced deceived you end up
and leaving Islam and this reminds me of
a famous e a famous story of of a person
who left the lands of
Islam and went because of a
woman now his intention was because of a
woman and someone saw him in the land of
the Romans mhm when I think sham or was
still under the Roman
occupation and he said weren't you one
of the people who memorized the
Quran yeah but I moved here this that he
left Islam he married some pretty woman
right and he
said yeah he's like he's like something
strange I only
remember couple verses from the Quran I
forgot everything wow and he
said I remember
only I think it
starts it may be uh forgive me if I'm
making a mistake bit tired now but it
may
be it may be that those who disbelieve
wish that they would have been Muslims
or submission you know he's like that's
all I remember wow that's all I remember
subh Allah so
you sell your
Dean for fame for a woman for whatever a
man
cannot a man has to have his
priority Allah always no matter what the
world says no matter who whatever
happens Allah first you put Allah first
all your Affairs in this D will be
sorted I mean it's kind of really it's
nonsensical in a way and it's you can
understand because we've been there you
you can understand it's like sugar it's
sweet right but it's poison at the end
you you keep going with sugar it Toth
Decay you're going to get diabetes
you're going to get cancer and we know
the results of eating healthy right but
you know the lazy ways to go back
towards the feel good same thing over
here but when you look at sneo for
instance someone who you know this neon
knows him you know okay the life that
he's LED so he's right that's a witness
your first witness in front of you he's
telling you right there he's o got is he
does he have more status than this guy
probably right are they the same
whatever the case but he's okay I got
the status I but I'm telling you it's
not worth it they don't people don't
care about you it's at the end of the
day you can do much more by being
beneficial to society rather than what
being a clown you're just a clown just a
clown people laughing at you people ad
taking advantage of you like you have to
Val that's the beautiful thing about
Islam that it teaches you to have
respect for yourself MH a lot of people
don't get that they think Islam is just
about okay prayer no it teaches you to
Value the am the responsibility the
blessings that God has given you teaches
you to have
honor honor is huge in Islam
self-respect respect for others how you
deal with people as you said not being a
clown jumping up and out an
entertainer right and you see the
transition ofnow
more mature now the way he talks the way
he behaves mhm you you know more more
respectful and you see this person
acting like a clown and people treating
him like a clown mhm and you always get
deceived uh thinking you have time it's
like you have time but you go to the to
the graveyards how many
people they end up not coming back from
that party right you take that alcohol
you shouldn't be drinking and next thing
you're uh doing something uh that you
shouldn't be doing maybe you get behind
a wheel or who knows you just make
unerasable
mistakes and then you just keep going
down a road of Destruction you keep
digging a deeper hole and then you just
it is it's like the point some people
come back but then some some point it's
a it's a never there's always hope you
can can come back but the thing is you
don't know between that time and the
next day if you're going to be alive if
death will reach you and then it's too
late and you fail the test yeah you
that's the scary thing that's the scary
thing you don't know and
Shan is tricking you into thinking that
okay I have time I have time you don't
know it might today might might be our
last day tomorrow might be we don't know
right you have to be ready you cannot be
comfortable enough and safe enough to
think that okay that's it no we don't
know you have to be ready every single
moment not to mention that we're you
know we short our shortcomings our
mistakes right how can you give up your
faith man you have already enough
mistakes and sins and problems you're
giving up your faith that's like your
key to opening the door to the mercy of
Allah what is the most important thing
what would you tell neon someone like
him right now you're talking to him to
kind of get to plan a sea to create some
urgency in what we're
saying I would say listen to the people
people have been there where you trying
to go listen to the people who have
already lived that life that you're
chasing and they're telling you that
there's no happiness there there's only
short spikes of dopamin short spikes of
dopamin that's it that's it right no
longlasting
peace you want longlasting peace it's in
Islam you come back to the dean you make
Toba go take a shahada and you have
trust me trust Allah will honor you mhm
when you give doubt having that type of
platform so many young men watching him
Allah will give you honor these people
will respect you not make fun of you so
if you're really looking
for right seek it with Allah Allah will
give you is Allah will give you honor he
will honor you but if youve seeking
honor through the alcohol and all the
other stuff then Allah will dishonor you
Allah will definitely definitely
dishonor you so come back to the dean
man come back to Islam you know Islam
you've been given a gift and you're
kicking it you're kicking the gift to
the curb and you're making a disservice
so make sure do it today man make your
Toba today say shahada today fix
yourself today leave these losers leave
these and stick to your dean and use
your platform use your platform to
preach Islam use your platform to call
people to Islam these young men today
who are on these games spending hours
imagine if they hear you saying
something about Islam about the prophet
wasallam you could change their lives
you could change their lives these guys
are wasting time for hours and hours on
video games you could change their lives
if you say something about Islam if they
see wow look neon is a good musl okay
he's playing some games but he's telling
us about prayer he's telling guys stop
the game and go pray on time yeah then
you can come back to the game or
whatever right okay I know it's not the
best but you know you have a golden
opportunity man don't kick it because
all you're going to find is depression
and sadness you're not going to be happy
and one day your eyes are going to open
you're going to see that everyone around
you just used you and
ises four minutes left okay we'll wrap
up in two four
good and this is not complicated I mean
Islam is something that if you're
sincere you ask the creator of the
heavens and earth alone to guide you we
need help help we need guidance it is
straightforward the evidence is there
it's not just Blind Faith it's something
like sneo you look in the message is
very clear Lucid worship one and only
one God not his creation not your
desires not a man not a woman not
anything not your ideas not money not
fame and be morally upright and the
Quran is a living Miracle it's there if
somebody takes a look we got one minute
left what do you uh what would you tell
them if there's any doubts there for
anybody look into it look at the world
look at everything is point look at
what's happening right now somehow it
always leads back to the Muslims
everything that's happening in the world
the the spotlight is on the Muslims it's
on Islam No matter how much you try to
run away push it what is the world
always talking about it's about
Islam look into it man it's time has the
time not come has the time not come for
you to be honest with yourself for you
to acknowledge that you have doubts in
your head that you know that this life
is not right that you're not happy about
things has a time not come for you to
look at the one piece that you've been
avoiding for the longest time that
you're running away from that you afraid
of Islam is that look at it look give a
read to the Quran and sincerely ask the
creator of the heavens and the Earth to
guide you beautiful advice beautiful
advice in the book he just mentioned the
Quran go to the Deen show.com get it to
you I'll get it to you for free that's
right and we'll see you next time hope
you take this advice so you can be on
the path of success not destruction
subscribe hit that notification Bell so
you don't miss exciting programs like
this one until next time peace be with
you assalam
alaykum alhamdulillah brothers and
sisters we've acquired the future Dean
Center property and we want to get the
mashid open first it's all coming along
we're installing the doors we can make
woo we've installed the carpet we have
many details to finish up but it's
coming along alhamdulillah we need a new
roof we need new windows and we need a
minb but that's right we need a minb but
for the musjid now if all of you want to
be a part of history and help build a
house of worship build a musjid for the
sake of Allah so Allah the Creator can
build for you a house in Jenna click the
link below donate right now may God
Almighty Allah reward all of
you